don't like that i make fun of
bezos's little rocket but it's a cosmic
[ __ ] rocket it looks
come on it looks like a hitachi vibrator
some people were like oh all the space
shuttles and all the space things look
like built no no the space shuttles
the space shuttles look like airplanes
they did not look like wieners they did
not look like dildos they did not look
like the hitachi vibrator that you can
buy on amazon.com i don't know if that
was where jeff bezos got his inspiration
or if he was punked like someone's like
oh we're going to have a design contest
and someone's like well we're going to
make it look like a hitachi vibrator
that'd be funny
he'll never do that he did it
he did it 100 looks like
an oversized giant hitachi vibrator it's
a space dildo that's what i called it
and my feeling is here's here's what i
want to get across with this message of
william shatner i am not against william
shatner going into space i'm not against
jeff bezos paying for william shatner go
in space i wouldn't even mind if all the
billionaires on earth got on one
[ __ ] rocket went into space and
never came back don't give to [ __ ]
but i will say
if jeff bezos can pay for william
shatner to go into space and to come
back into earth
then he can afford to [ __ ] pay taxes
that is what we can do we can tax the
rich here if they can afford at this
point if they can afford to shoot
oversized hitachi vibrators into space
with captain kirk on them
they can afford taxes
that is what the [ __ ] we need to do it's
enough enough of dancing around and
acting like oh you're gonna stifle
growth and you're gonna hurt capitalism
and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
if they can afford to do that kind of
[ __ ] then they can afford taxes
that's all i'm saying and i'm not saying
we should take all their money so they
can't have their little space dildo fun
time or whatever whatever it is that
they're doing with the space travel
because it sounds like to me that
they're wanting to create a way for rich
people to get off this planet and go
somewhere else to be you know the elite
somewhere else and the rich somewhere
else which is fine by me we just need to
take all their [ __ ] money before they
go
because we're the ones who gave them
that [ __ ] money it's our
infrastructure it's our system of
capitalism it's our system the
government that has made it to where
those [ __ ] have made the money
that they made
and giving them the money to shoot the
[ __ ] dildos into space
that is how it works
that is how it works
we do not need to redistribute the
wealth to the moon or to another planet
we got one right here and william
shatner describes it when he breaks
through the atmosphere that he looked
down and there is life there it is right
there in front of you there's life
and we're concerned about the black
space
of death
he says
william shatner that is
says is it death he's talking about the
endlessness of space
that was his question when he reached
back down on the ground and he's he's
overwhelmed by emotion at this point
because this is actually pretty
incredible to see william shatner
captain kirk a person that we you know
in our minds has been the space and
lived in space right
to watch him
react to the actually leaving the
earth's atmosphere not
not in a hollywood movie set but in real
life
and realizing
how extraordinary that is
but also realizing the significance of
earth and everyone on and everything on
earth and we're going to talk about
climate change a little bit here in a
bit about the build back better act
because that's part of it
and we just we just made it to where
jeff bezos can spend the money to get
again i'm not against bezos sending
captain kirk into space fine if that's
what the [ __ ] you want to do with your
money whatever
whatever it just you don't get to keep
you don't get to keep all the money that
anyhow is going to work
and anyhow we should do this
we should tax the [ __ ] rich
we should tax them
that
is how it should work
and one reason why um we should do this
is for that buildback better act um
there's been a lot of let me let me show
you my tweet
on shatner so here's what i said if
william shatner can go to space then we
can tax the [ __ ] rich tax the rich i
i again i'm not saying william shatner
shouldn't go to space i'm just saying
just saying if we can get him to go to
space and jeff bezos can pay for him to
go to space then what we should do
what we should do is tax jeff bezos
because obviously he has enough [ __ ]
money
if he can
send captain kirk on the cosmic [ __ ]
rocket to go to space now uh don's non
wins will also tweet i want to show you
him he says hey world can we send the
for the people act to space with william
shatner so it gets the same [ __ ]
attention and priority let me know
the best
don winslow because i think that is the
thing here is that
we're paying attention
to
captain kirk william shatner going into
space he was trending at one number one
on twitter all day long almost all day
until
hashtag lauren bowmer lauren bobert is
so dumb started trending it went to
number one of course
but we can't figure out how to make sure
that the build
buildback better act
before the people act
all these important things
are trending
we need to get election reform we need
to get infrastructure we need to get
human infrastructure passed
we need to get the george ford policing
act passed
we need to kill the filibuster is what
we need to do
enough of this minority rule
[ __ ] democracy stuff the majority of
the country wants these things and we
need to pass them we have the majority
we formed a government it's time and
enough of this yapping about what the
numbers gonna be
with joe manchin and cinema and the
progressives enough of that [ __ ] who
cares what the [ __ ] number is no one
get no one gives a [ __ ] no one gives a
[ __ ]
no one gives two [ __ ] what the number's
gonna be the only reason why we're
arguing about the [ __ ] number is
because this is a republican tactic
this is a republican tactic to get you
talk about the [ __ ] number so you
think that you're spending all kinds of
money that you don't have
that's all [ __ ] that's all [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they spent they spent
tons of money on that on on tax breaks
for the rich
tons
tons of deficit money
trillions of dollars
on making sure that the rich got to keep
all their [ __ ] money and here we are
sending captain kirk into space with
jeff bezos's money that he got to keep
because we decided that was a good idea
to run up the deficit that way to not
tax
the wealthiest
in this country
but now now we gotta have this
conversation about how much the the
[ __ ] infrastructure bill is this
number that number it doesn't get it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
it doesn't matter what the number is who
gives to [ __ ] what the number is
what matters is what's in the bill and
what it's going to do because here's the
thing the reason why the number doesn't
[ __ ] matter the reason why it doesn't
matter is because in the bill it's
[ __ ] paid for
it's [ __ ] paid for it's paid for by
taking their space dildo money that is
how we pay for it
that's how we pay for the infrastructure
that's how we pay for the human
infrastructure and if you want to see
what's in this bill i came up with the
graphic here it's not fantastic but i'll
tell you
there's two years free community college
in the buildback better act this is
beyond
the physical infrastructure this is
beyond the the roads the bridges the
internet that we're going to get which
is going to
it's going to dump 1.1 trillion dollars
into the economy over the next several
years when they're building and
repairing the roads and bridges and
infrastructure in this country the
physical infrastructure
we have two years free of community
college
that's that's incredible and the reason
why it's incredible we also have child
care and universal pre-k those two
components those two educational
components are something that we
desperately desperately need in this
country and if you don't think that we
desperately need
uh education in this country just run on
over to facebook
and look at the ivermectin institute
facebook groups that your uncle ned and
aunt sally's on
go check out the comments over there and
you can tell me whether we need some
[ __ ] education up in this son of a
[ __ ]
because we hundred percent need some
[ __ ] education it's getting
absolutely ridiculous
and it all starts with making sure that
children are off on the right foot you
know using critical thinking and logic
and to continue that with when they
leave high school to make sure that they
can enter into the economy in the
workforce
with possibly a a
a degree from a community college at the
bare minimum
and i i i
not just saying community college
but also trade schools because we need
trades too
but this is all part of that this is all
part of making sure that our population
isn't [ __ ] dumb like lauren bobert
hashtag lauren bobert is so [ __ ] dumb
and that's what we get
that's what we get when we don't have
child care and universal pre-k pre-k
preschool
and two free years of community college
to make sure people you know got some
goddamn brains
the other thing that it does is medicare
expansion
oh well we're going to talk about social
security here in just a bit and how it
got a raise
this expands medicaid medicare now
there's some debate over the medicare
because oh joe manchin wants to go ahead
and make it solvent before we expand it
to vision and dental well let's do it
both at the same [ __ ] time
dummy stop arguing over the goddamn
number who gives a [ __ ] what the number
is it doesn't matter what the number is
it doesn't [ __ ] matter and the reason
why it doesn't matter is because we are
going to tax the rich
i'll give you an example here in a
minute i'll tell you exactly how what
the plan on that is
the democrats want to extend the child
tax credit this is that monthly amount
that's going into your account every
month if you have children
uh some it's 250 some it's 300 per child
and it's up to a certain amount and you
have to make under a certain amount of
money whether you're a household of two
or household of one
but the extended tax child tax credit
they want to extend that to 2025.
so all the people out there that are
receiving this tax credit into their
bank account
every month
they're gonna this bill will extend it
to 2025.
boy with ever all these republicans
including kevin mccarthy bitching and
moaning and complaining about inflation
i wonder what could help families that
have children with inflation
i wonder what could help that after
we're trying to struggle to get along
here with inflation after the pandemic
because it won't [ __ ] end because you
people won't do what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to do
which is end it and go get vaccinated
the next thing that it does is cut
prescription drug prices i'm not you
don't even have to go any further than
that
how how the [ __ ] can we disagree on
cutting prescription drug prices at this
point
is this even a [ __ ] disagreement is
this the thing that they're debating
back and forth between each other who
gives a [ __ ] how much it cost
no one gives a [ __ ] how much it cost the
reason why no one should give a [ __ ] how
much it cost is because it's costing the
american people nothing
besides besides the top tax rates that's
the only people that it's gonna cost any
money to anybody
that's it it's not gonna cost the
working average family any [ __ ] money
none
speaking of
working families it's also gonna get
paid family and medical leave
12 weeks
a paid family and medical leave
so people can when they have a [ __ ]
baby you pro-lifers out there
they really are pro-life aren't they oh
as george carlin says when you're in
when you're in the fetus
we're all for you
but when you're born you're [ __ ]
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave paid
do you hear that it's [ __ ] paid not
unpaid you don't have to build up your
vacation
you don't have to do any of that it's
paid
so that when that life comes into the
world you can make sure that you give
the first 12 weeks of that life
that baby you pro-lifers who love to
clamor on and on and on
about this [ __ ] until they until till
they're born then you don't want
anything to do with those [ __ ]
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave
and then it has provisions to combat
climate change which
here we are back to the william shatner
thing when he looks down on earth and he
realizes that that is the life
that's the lifeblood that's why we live
that's why we're here that's why jeff
bezos can build an oversized hitachi
vibrator and
send captain kirk into space
is because we have life on earth
and it's precious
and we don't have much time
so there
those are the things that are in the
buildback better act
but let's talk about let's talk about
how these things are [ __ ] paid for
because i'm [ __ ] i'm for one and sick
and [ __ ] tired of hearing
about how it's gonna be paid for and the
amount of money who
gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't matter what
the [ __ ] number is number one it's
over a 10-year period so this idea that
somehow the american people are gonna
shell out three and a half trillion two
and a half trillion one point one tree
whatever the [ __ ] number is [ __ ]
all [ __ ]
because it's not like joe biden's just
gonna write a three and a half trillion
dollar check you stupid [ __ ]
it's over a ten-year period
whatever the number ends up being i
don't care if it's 10 trillion don't
give two [ __ ] here's why i don't give a
[ __ ]
because inside the buildback better act
you know what it does it raises
corporate tax rates by five measly
points
five measly points and my guess is that
they're going to try to find all kinds
of loopholes to get out of it because
also in the billback better act
it gives the government funds
to make sure that those tax rates are
enforced by the irs
to make sure that they're not skating on
it you know you know committing tax
fraud like
uh you know something like a cheeto dust
mobster or grandpa poopy pants or
something like that you know
i'm sure we won't find out of any
attacks we're gonna talk about that here
in a little bit uh trump organization
tax fraud we're gonna talk about that
here in a little bit but the corporate
tax rate is gonna go up five percent
five measly points
if you make under four hundred thousand
dollars a year under four hundred
thousand
if you make under four hundred thousand
dollars a year
it's going to go up 2.6 measly points
2.6 measly points and that's going to
pay for all this all of it
all of it the roads the bridges
the the pre-k the community college the
medicare expansion
all of it
the climate change part of the bill the
prescription lowering the prescription
drug cost
so if you make over four hundred
thousand dollars a year number one
congratulations
but yeah you will have to pay a little
more if you make over four hundred
thousand you'll have to pay just to
smidge more just a smidge just a smidge
to make sure that everyone in this
country
gets all those things that we have
actually have some [ __ ] human
infrastructure and some investment some
real
life investment into working class
people and the human infrastructure of
the american people
the next thing that it pays for here's
the next thing we got more money because
it does and then again it doesn't
[ __ ] matter how much money it does
not matter it doesn't matter because the
capital gains rates are going to go up
by five measly points
so all those people that avoid
actual being taxed income taxed
because they avoid income tax because
their majority of their income is from
capital gains and no you don't get the
slide anymore
we're gonna put five more points five
measly more points
people in the 1960s and 1970s the tax
rate was 70 [ __ ] percent
up until late 80s it was 50 [ __ ]
percent
we're down into the low 20s the actual
attacker it's down
just above 10 sometimes below 10 of the
actual tax rates after deductions and
all loopholes that they get
70 percent in the 1960s and 1970s
that was the high tax rate that was the
highest tax rate
70
percent
we can afford this stuff we've always
been able to afford this stuff
always we just been affording
millionaires billionaires and
trillionaires
the ability to build oversized rockets
oversized dildo rockets to launch them
into space
and to
try to come up with some way to colonize
some other planet or a moon or something
well we have colonization here
and if you're pro-life
and you're not for this bill you're not
[ __ ] pro-life
i guaran damn to you that
garen god damn to you that
so let's stop talking about the [ __ ]
money who gives a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
money is
who gives to
[ __ ]
no one gives a [ __ ]
no one should give a [ __ ] and the reason
why you shouldn't give a [ __ ] because in
the bill the rich pay for the
[ __ ] and they should [ __ ] pay
for the [ __ ] tax the rich
tax them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them